well Ukraine has launched what appears
to be the biggest wave of airstrikes
into Russia since the start of the war
Ukrainian drones targeted these six
regions in Russian territory because
city was the hardest hit a large fire
started at an airport where several
military planes were also damaged there
were also attacks in near Moscow that
led to flights at several airports being
suspended
further south there have been reports of
drones being shot down and briyan's
Kaluga Oriel and riazan regions these
attacks went unusually deep into Russian
territory and Mark a major escalation in
Ukraine's use of drone Warfare Robert
Bryant has more
this was one of the most intensive
exchanges of missile and drone strikes
so far in the war
attacked drones struck six regions
inside Russia with the most Northerly
Target an air base near the city of
pascov where it's reported more than 20
drones were used starting large fires
four giant transport planes on the
ground were hit although the extent of
the damage is disputed by both sides
Moscow says it downed many of the
attacking drones accusing Kiev of
targeting civilians assisted by its
Western backers
Ukrainian drone attacks on civilian
objects confirm the terrorist essence of
the cube regime once again it's clear
that Ukrainian drones weren't able to
fly those distances without assistance
from Western satellite information
Russia has warned the strikes will not
go unpunished as is often the case
Ukraine hasn't confirmed it's behind
these latest strikes merely referring to
them cryptically as accidents happening
on Russian territory but leaders in Kiev
say that airbases used to launch attacks
on Ukrainian territory are legitimate
targets
just before Daybreak Wednesday much of
Kiev was awoken by a series of
explosions as more than 40 Russian
drones and missiles targeted the city in
waves from all directions with Ukraine
claiming to have shot down nearly all of
them
but there were casualties with several
people killed and injured in what's said
to be the largest Russian attack in
months with every indication of more
airstrikes from both sides to come Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Keith
well joining us live now from Northern
Ukraine is Ukrainian Army Captain
Vladimir omalyan he was also the former
minister of infrastructure of Ukraine
Captain Moscow is saying these are your
drones and that they targeted civilians
what do you say to that
hello I'm very happy to be with you
thank you for having me uh concerning uh
this particular situation uh we see that
war is ongoing and we didn't start this
war but definitely Ukraine will conclude
this war by victory over Kremlin what
happened this night in six regions of
Russia
it's only the beginning
and uh
uh whatever Russians say our Prime
objects are military bases and uh
military uh potential of Russian Empire
so it's our Prime important importance
to conclude the living and existing so
to be very clear Captain you're saying
that these were your drones that there
will be more and that you've been
targeting military infrastructure
I think that uh era of dominancy of
Russia in aviation and drones is over
Ukraine will not stand uh the situation
that only uh via on the permanent
Russian attacks and Russian military
first of all
get used to the thought that they are on
the permanent uh their apartment targets
for Ukraine militaries as well Ukraine
has been somewhat reluctant to take
responsibility for well targets and
attacks inside inside Russia especially
around Moscow I'm wondering if that's
changing especially now we're seeing
this demonstration of clear long-range
capability here
I wouldn't say that we refrain from any
kind of attacks on Russian territory and
we always said that it's not only
Ukrainian territory to be on the world
the same will happen to Russia and
Russians brought War to Ukraine we will
bring it back and frankly saying I've
seen that drone industry is booming
right now and we are coming uh to New
Era of uh War Trends unfortunately we
are not also happy with that but we are
not the first one to start it and uh if
we see that there is something important
for us to be destroyed on Russian
territory we will do that
well let me ask you then as you say
we're entering a new phase of the war
would you say that Ukraine's
counter-offensive strategy is yielding
the results you were looking for it's
been going a little more slowly perhaps
than many anticipated
it's not a Hollywood movie and it takes
Bloods and it takes lives and definitely
we are not ready to sacrifice every life
of our soldier we would like to make
them believe that's why that it's not a
blitz group uh as Russians thought it
will be but it's successful and you see
that since recently we break through
this so-called uh suraw weekend line or
a Russian
Russian trenches
which we call her sometimes and progress
of Ukrainian troops in this house is
visible uh Captain I understand you were
not a fighter when this war broke out a
lot has obviously changed since then I
know you have a family children at home
how is the war now viewed by the people
at home around Ukraine
yes it's a difficult challenge for us
and as Aboriginal Commander uh solution
once said that war starts with
profession professional soldiers and
ends with musician managers or PR
Specialists it means that human power is
not endless one but we do understand
that we should fight and there is no
alternative for us and we fight for our
kids as you rightly said for our
families which are behind our backs and
this is the best motivation and this is
the best moral for all Ukrainian Army to
stand still and to fight Russians
Ukrainian Army captain
Vermilion there speaking to us from
Northern Ukraine thank you so much for
joining us here on Al Jazeera Captain
great tip to get the latest from you
thank you